[Musique]
alain merci beaucoup de classe ce soir
alors je vous le dis ces images jurons
ni à mettre tous pensé toute la journée
vraiment c'est incroyable c'est que
j'étais ému depuis que je les ai eus j'y
pense tout le temps c'est ça un maillot
aussi mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
elle a plein qui veulent pas les voir
j'ai pas plus je vous le dis j'ai pas pu
lire voir mais j'ai vu une fois parce
que je vois là je suis mais je n'ai pas
pu le revoir
c'est difficile pour moi de les revoir
parce que quelque part c'est la fin d'un
c'est la fin de ces la fin des reculs
quoi donc quelque part c c'est difficile
quand vous avez récupéré cet animal qui
était qui était condamné puisque quelque
part sa mère avaient été tués
vous en avez récupéré trois petits comme
ça qui vous tombent du ciel d'une petite
journée à peine et puis vous essayez de
les laisser dans le parc en pensant
qu'une mère va les reprendre et bats la
nature ça se fait pas ça se fait pas
comme ça donc le lendemain vous revenez
et puis en a deux qui sont morts et le
dernier qui est blottie contre les deux
autres est vraiment le choix il ya deux
tués à bout portant c'est c'est horrible
ça mais ça je l'aï su parce que le
problème de l'assassinât excusez moi de
prendre le mot mal bien sûr je n'ai pas
d'autres je suis d'accord et assassinats
des reculs c'était quelque chose que
j'ai appris bien plus tard il ya une
omerta au niveau de la chasse l'ate
s'est produit devant plusieurs témoins
comme vous pouvez le voir avec des gens
qui connaissent le parent qui
connaissent qu'ils connaissent et
hercules qui connaissent l'amour que je
peux avoir pour les animaux et personne
n'a rien dit on a tu es très très proche
des reculs c'était lui donnait même le
biberon c'est ce qu'on dit et ça nous a
vous n'avez pas de chorizo vous êtes son
père vous êtes à sa mère il a que vous
les gens qui aiment les animaux peuvent
ressentir ce que j'ai que j'ai pu
ressentir port hercule savez un animal
et il vous donne tout c'est vrai non
mais vraiment je comprends tout à fait
ce conserver et je sais pas si vous avez
des animaux
si c'est vrai je tuerai votre chien à
non mais cette fois ci je me suis
exactement mis dans cette situation là
et je me suis dit mais ça serait ce que
je vaux rible parce que je peux
reprocher aux gens qui ont assisté à
cette
la personne qui l'a fait aux gens qu'ils
ont su c'est pas demeurant d'hercule
ils n'ont même pas rendue ils ont ouvert
il y avait encore le le lait et le lait
pâtes que je venais d'huile données du
matin tous les matins il avait sa
gamelle
il m'aurait appelée m'aurait dit
monsieur martin on a fait une bêtise pas
dans les conditions qu'elle a de la
réalité dans dix ans on a on a tué recul
sur un sur un groupe de sangliers qui
partait et que quelque part ça ça a fait
que connan qu'on savait pas c'est pas
bon ça prend ça peut excuser le geste
mais la tuer un animal gratuitement
comme ça a été fait en le quasiment le
cas récent parce que maman bébé il
cherchait bien sûr ça ils vont chercher
à seyssins savez ça voit pas très bien
mais ça sent énormément vient donc
quelque part il a fait tous les gens tac
tac c'est pas lui c'est pas lui
donc on fait qu'alain on vient sur les
pattes arrière un moment pour voir c'est
pas lui donc on continue les gens qui
étaient là d'ailleurs vous verrez au
niveau de la vidéo si vous l'avez écouté
même disque un moment pourquoi t'as fait
ça pour agir c'est s'était pas à faire
c'est un geste pour moi qui ai pas
pardonnable mais ce qui l'est plus c'est
l'omerta ouais c'est ça c'est ça qui me
gêne c'est que les gens le sachent ans
les gens le y ont vu les gens ayant
assisté à la scène
dix bons on a fait une bêtise sans lui
rend son sanglant bien sûr vu rentrer ça
je vais vous dire quelque chose monsieur
hanouna
je me suis je vais je me serais fait
enterrer le qui recule tellement je la
mets ces dames bien j'ai 60 ans c'est
incroyable ce que vous dites bah oui
j'aime les animaux
j'ai mon grand biniou qui a été blessé
par balle il ya deux trois ans je lui ai
fait un cercueil de 2 m par 1 1 les gens
vont dire il est complet non malades
sont compromis là il a un pet au casque
leurs jours il n'a pas du tout à fait
aux casques bonal 1 c'est vraiment il a
un amour pour ces animaux que je
comprends tout à fait journal et quand
je vous dis avec tout le monde et est
dans le même état que vous ça ça a
vraiment de sensibiliser tout le monde
on est on est tellement triste pour ce
qui s'est passé ça me fera parvenir
hercules mais ce soir si je suis sur
votre plateau c'est pour quelque part
faire justice à hercules qui soit pas
voir comme ça gratuitement sur 1 sur 1
sur 1 sur une personne qui a décidé que
c'était qu'un c'était qu'un sanglier ça
compte pas un sanglier sais rien mais
pour moi ça n'assure que ça compte
vous savez je vais vous dire une chose
j'ai eu plus de peine peut-être pour
hercules que pour certaines personnes
qui pouvaient qui sont partis qui bien
sûr tiens je comprends la peine quand on
perd un animal c'est moi pour moi les
alice semblable quand on perd ils
veulent un être cher aussi voilà parce
qu'un animal moi je moi je me suis mis à
votre place c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai un
petit chêne à la maison de trois ans
mais je la considère pas comme quelqu'un
de ma famille cc voilà c'est je moi je
m'inquiète pour elle quand un parent et
ça ces images là quand je les ai vus je
me suis mis je me suis imaginé que je
vois ces images sur mon animal mais
c'est une sagesse c'est traumatisant